being in New York one is surrounded by
real estate and you're sort of
constantly aware of it we really knew
that there was a better solution to be
had for how we experienced real estate
digitally my name is David Eisenberg I'm
the co-founder and CEO of floored got
started in the middle of 2012 when we
became aware that there wasn't a viable
3d solution for interactive
communication for the real estate
industry at that time instead of looking
at two-dimensional black and white floor
plans what about looking through full
color completely immersive totally
accurate three-dimensional models of
spaces that was a vision that we all got
excited about and so we started a
company to really execute on that we've
used a variety of virtual reality
devices to help people feel what it's
like to be inside we can take a tenant
and actually place them inside of a
space that they're considering
purchasing at Florida we really believe
that virtual reality can make life
better by building digital experiences
that actually mirror or parallel what's
possible in the real world and so in
everything that we do we need our
computing to be super fast we've always
been on the latest Hardware on the
latest processors there's an Intel
processor in every computer in the
company we really benefit when Intel
moves the needle on the speed of
processing on things like the Intel 2 +
1 PC that are flexible or agile in terms
of how one interacts with the device you
can touch to move furniture you can walk
through a space using your hand that's
the same exact functionality that will
be really helpful the ability to lay out
a space these are all experiences that
may work better in 3d than in
traditional 2d
some of my favorite projects are ones
that I know are going to touch a lot of
people take the example of a physically
disabled person who might want to go and
visit a museum halfway around the world
now imagine sitting down in your home
office and being able to virtually
travel there every year as we're
upgrading our computing to get faster
and faster we're looking to Intel to
develop newer and faster devices which
will in turn allow us to build software
that will deliver a better experience to
our custom